je m'appelle dominique j'ai 45 ans et
j'ai une maladie psychiatrique
je suis persuadé que ma vie est un match
de foot contre le néant
c'est assez grave hein comme pathologie
je me souviens d'ailleurs parfaitement
de l'ouverture du score c'est le néant
qui a marqué en premier le match avait
commencé depuis à peine une dizaine
d'années j'étais encore enfant
on rentrait de vacances avec mes parents
et mes frères et dans la voiture je
rêvassais en regardant les paysages
défilent et par la fenêtre
je me souviens encore il y avait une
belle lumière d'ouest qui rendait la
campagne superbe
ce jour là j'avais décidé d'affronter
mon adversaire d'aller le provoquer en
face à face les yeux dans les yeux
alors je me suis mis à imaginer la
disparition de toute chose
la disparition de mes parents de mes
frères puis ma propre disparition
puis la disparition de toute la matière
et de toutes formes d'énergie jusqu'à la
vacuité totale jusqu'au néant et la
butte
1 à 0 pour le néant je crois pouvoir
dire que j'ai ressenti dans mon ventre
la terreur absolue c'était comme si
chacune des cellules de mon corps
avaient été électrocutées par une peur
panique
j'étais complètement pétrifiée au bout
de quelques minutes j'ai repris mes
esprits je me suis dit il est vraiment
balèze comme un adversaire va falloir
être bon pour gagner
et dans le même temps j'étais super
excitée je me disais ça y est maintenant
je sais ce que je veux faire dans la vie
moi quand je serai grand je veux gagner
contre le néant ou alors je sais que
c'est pas évident à s'imaginer quand on
me voit comme ça avec mon petit gène xxs
et mon maillot acheté au rayon 14 mais
mentalement je suis un viking
je suis un guerrier je suis un
belliqueux je suis une teigne
je vais vous dire un truc j'ai une arme
secrète une sorte de super pouvoirs vous
avez compris que le néant utilise la
peur comme arme de destruction massive
ben moi j'utilise la confiance je sais
pas comment ça marche je sais pas d'où
ça me vient je sait transmettre la
confiance c'est peut-être la seule chose
que je sais faire dans la vie c'est déjà
pas mal vous savez parce qu'avec la
confiance on peut changer le monde à
propos de monde
j'ai passé une bonne partie de la
première mi temps dans le monde de
l'entreprise
alors l'entreprise je sais pas si vous
connaissez mais c'est un terrain de jeu
qui adore le néon ya plein
il ya plein de gens malheureux partout
plein de gens qui ont peur de tout de
leur chef de leurs collègues de leurs
clients peur d'être viré peur de rater
leur vie et ça commence dès la formation
si vous interrogez n'importe quelle
promotion d'écoles d'ingénieurs ou de
commerce vous aurez au moins la moitié
des étudiants qui vous dira les yeux
dans le vague
non mais moi je voulais le chanteur de
rock ou explorateurs je crois qu'il ya
un mot qui a fait beaucoup de mal dans
l'entreprise c'est le mot management
system en horribles sur le management je
le sais ça fait 20 ans que je suis
manager le management c'est l'armé
fatale du néant dans l'entreprise un
jour en allant au marché
je suis tombé sur ce magnifique graffiti
plutôt chômeurs que manager
pour le type qui a fait ça c'est un
génie ce que j'adore surtout c'est sa
façon d'orthographier manager eur1 à la
française parce que c'est vrai que c'est
louche quand même se moquer un impact
sur la vie de centaines de millions de
gens dans le monde et qu'on sait même
pas traduire et si vous chercher la
définition dans wikipédia car rien de
clair la seule explication à peu près
convaincante
c'est le lien étymologique avec le verbe
italien manage arrêt qui est un terme
d'équitation et qui signifie tenir en
main les rênes d'un cheval
après faut pas s'étonner que les gens
soient malheureux dans les entreprises
pourtant franchement c'est pas compliqué
de faire de belles choses
il suffit de dire aux gens j'ai
confiance en vous et ça marche à tous
les coups
aujourd'hui par exemple je suis
directeur de clinique une des plus
grosses cliniques de france il ya 1300
personnes
et je vais vous dire un truc directeur
comme boulot c'est super fastoche il
suffit de dire aux gens j'ai confiance
en vous et vous pouvez faire des trucs
super même avec vos actionnaires un jour
par exemple j'ai dit aux médecins
actionnaires de la clinique
je vous propose d'inverser le modèle
capitaliste
vous savez le capitalisme c'est quand
des actionnaires touchent des dividendes
sur le fruit du travail des salariés
moi je leur ai proposé linverse
je leur ai dit je vous propose de
prélever un pourcentage de vos revenus
d'actionnaires pour constituer un
treizième mois pour les salariés
moi j'ai pas eu droit tout de suite un
instant ni mauvais chemin
mais j'avais confiance en eux et
finalement ils ont voté oui à
l'unanimité en assemblée générale quand
vous dites aux gens j'ai confiance en
vous alors il vous propose des idées
merveilleuse ça c'est christine qui
voulait faire du service de
chimiothérapie
un musée d'art moderne ça c'est
françoise qui voulait organiser des
séances de sevrage tabagique pour les
patients les salariés ça c'est olivier
qui voulait faire un potager bio sur un
toit-terrasse de la clinique
ça c'est luce qui voulaient organiser un
parcours découverte de l'hôpital pour
les enfants des écoles et des classes ça
c'est yves le chef cuistot qui voulait
monter un partenariat avec un centre de
réinsertion de personnes handicapées qui
plante aujourd'hui nos champs de
carottes de patates et de poireaux voyez
mon boulot à moi on peut pas dire que ça
soit compliqué ça consiste à dire merci
quand vous dites aux gens j'ai confiance
en vous alors quelques fois ça peut même
devenir magnifique ça c'est l'histoire
de céline une infirmière de la clinique
qui soigne un petit garçon très malade
comme ce petit garçon était fan de
pompiers céline a carrément appelé une
caserne pour qu'il puisse réaliser son
rêve et monter dans un camion ça c'est
jean françois et sébastien qui un jour
sont venus me voir et m'ont dit
dominique il y actuellement un patient
en fin de vie dans le service de
pneumologie
il doit se marier avec sa compagne pour
des questions patrimoniales
ça va se passer dans sa chambre est ce
que tu nous autorise à lui préparer un
vrai repas de mariage
ben oui bien sûr alors ils ont mis les
petits plats dans les grands
ils se sont habillés comme un masterchef
avec des cloches en argent et tout ça et
c'était beau à pleurer quand vous dites
aux gens j'ai confiance en vous et
qu'ils se mettent à leur tour à
transmettre de la confiance autour d'eux
alors là c'est l'instant de grâce
je fais régulièrement des immersions
dans les services vous savez un peu
comme si ma vie je vais me regarder avec
les brancardiers
j'apprends passé la monobrosse avec les
femmes de ménage
j'apprends laver les instruments la
stérilisation
donc quand je vais au boulot que c'est
pas moi qui opéra et bien pendant une de
ces immersions deux aides soignants ont
demandé d'assister à la toilette au lit
d'une patiente
c'était une dame d'environ 80 ans qui
n'avait plus toute sa tête qui était
très fatigué et qu'il ne parlait
pratiquement plus pendant la toilette
les aides-soignants me disait avez vous
remarqué comme cette dame a confiance en
nous comme elle est détendue comme ses
muscles sont relâchés quand on la
manipule et vous savez comment on a
gagné sa confiance parce que la semaine
dernière c'était pas du tout le cas ce
week-end on lui à laver les cheveux et
on l'a coiffé pendant plus d'une heure
et demie on pense qu'on lui a redonné sa
dignité
et aujourd'hui elle a confiance en nous
ce jour là mon coeur s'est envolé je
savais que je venais d égaliser à un
partout
quelques jours après mon petit frère est
venu manger à la maison alors mon petit
frère
il est très intelligent il est
psychologue il me dit est ce que tu
connais cette phrase de lacan et mais
c'est donner ce qu'on n'a pas à
quelqu'un qui n'en veut pas bon c'est
bien de phrases de psycho rien on sent
que c'est vrai mais on n'est pas sûr de
tout comprendre
et là j'ai eu la révélation
alors mesdames et messieurs maintenant
il va falloir vous concentrer parce que
vous allez assister en direct à une
découverte scientifique majeure qui
pourrait changer le destin de l'humanité
j'ai remplacé le mot aimer par le mot
manager et s'adonne manager c'est donner
ce qu'on n'a pas quelqu'un qui n'en veut
pas incroyable c'est la définition
exacte du management
mais oui c'est bien ça le management
c'est donner ce qu'on n'a pas des gens
qui n'en veulent pas d'ogm delà des
managers et vous confirmons donc aimé et
manager en fait c'est la même chose
le management en réalité c'est tout
simplement l'amour
d'ailleurs au début les organigrammes ça
devait ressembler à ça un conseil de
bienveillance un président amoureux
général une bien-aimée des ressources
humaines un amant ministre hâtif et
financier et tout un tas de petits
amoureux de service mais comme il était
trop timide
les inventeurs du management ils ont
préféré utiliser un mot qui veut rien
dire de la même façon quand un fonds
d'investissement dit un manager vous
allez me virer 200 personnes pour que je
puisse augmenter mon ebitda de 2 ou 3
points
en fait ce qui veut dire inconsciemment
s'est dit assez 200 personnes qu'on les
aime beaucoup mais c'est un sentiment
refoulé vous comprenez c'est un peu
comme de la pudeur ses adorables
bon je vous avoue qu'après cette
découverte
je me suis vu avec le prix nobel j'ai
chopé la grosse tête comme on dit et
j'ai pris un but en contre
un soir ma femme dit dis donc tu t'es
pas un peu empâté toi au niveau du coup
je me suis dit au ciel qui est gonflé on
peut pas dire que la morphologie d'un
type empâté quand même mais c'est vrai
que j'ai une grosse heure à la gorge la
alors le lendemain examen dans ma
clinique préféré et à midi la bonne
nouvelle qui tombe un médecin me reçoit
me dit monsieur le directeur ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a qu'une chance sur
quatre que ce soit un cancer
ah ouais quand même donc intervention
chirurgicale prélèvements pour analyse
et attend des résultats alors la tente
des résultats pour ceux qui connaissent
pas encore c'est un moment
particulièrement propice à
l'introspection
moi je me rappelle je me disais est ce
que tu es vraiment sûrs d'avoir dit à
tes enfants que tu les aimes et surtout
est-ce que tu la fais du mieux que tu
pouvais et comment ils pourraient le
matérialiser ce n'était plus là et là
j'ai pris un but pour la deuxième fois
de ma vie j'ai ressenti dans mon ventre
la grande peur et comme la première fois
j'ai été sauvé par une image mentale
cette fois ce fut l'image du collier de
nouilles fin ou du cendrier en pâte à
sel si vous préférez vous savez ces
cadeaux improbable que les enfants
fabriquent pour la fête des pères et
pour la fête des mères et qui vous offre
de tout leur coeur mais moi c'était
décidé j'allais fabrique un collier de
nouilles pour mes enfants j'imaginais
une sorte d'oeuvre musical fait de
chansons d'amour que j'aurais écrites
composées et interprétées pour mes
enfants
ce serait magnifique un problème quand
même je chante faux et je ne connais
absolument rien en musique
mais vous me connaissez je suis une
teigne
alors pendant deux ans toutes les nuits
et tous les week-ends
j'ai appris la musique bon quand vous
apprenez à la musique à 40 ans c'est un
peu comme un ski pour rester toujours un
peu en chasse neige et ça sera jamais
très élégant mais ça m'est complètement
égal
mon après mon note après note chanson
après chanson disque après disque je
construis désormais et jusqu'à la fin de
mes jours
une oeuvre musicale pour mes enfants une
sorte de cathédrale d'amour alors une
cathédrale en pâte à sel évidemment mal
fichu mallegol est un peu ridicule et
parfaitement insignifiant d'un point de
vue artistique mais ça m'est
complètement égal
je suis aujourd'hui complètement rassuré
je sais que je fais du mieux que je peux
pour dire à mes enfants que je les aime
de toutes mes forces et de toute mon âme
alors si on fait les comptes ça fait 2
partout à 45 ans je suis déjà dans la
deuxième mi-temps de ma vie et pour
avoir bien observé le néant en première
période
je sais que pour gagner contre lui il
faut jouer collectif
il faut qu'ils aient un maximum de
joueurs d'ailleurs ça devrait être le
grand projet de l'humanité ça gagner
notre match contre le néant
j'aurai plein d'idées à proposer je suis
sûr par exemple que dans cette salle il
ya plein de joueurs
alors je vous propose une petite
expérience je vais vous apprendre à
nîmes
vous savez au foot avant le match
important on chante les in mais moi je
me suis fabriqué un hymne pour mon match
de foot contre le néant alors c'est pas
un hymne qui se mure l'un c'est pas un
haka ça ressemble plutôt à une prière
une prière fabrication maison vous avez
compris
donc façon collier de nouilles donc il y
aura besoin d'un maximum d'indulgence de
votre part vous êtes prêts vous n'avez
jamais chanté dean et ça se voit vous
savez normalement pendant les îles tout
le monde doit poser la main sur le coeur
comme ça voulait bien c'est bon tout le
monde est prêt allez c'est parti
je
dans le froid
sidéral
un espoir minérale
à l'abri
des paupières
après
il
si cette fidèle c'était noël
si c'était en vain si c'était pour rien
si celle entre 3,6 et notre loi
si c'est notre chance
si c'est une autre danse
voilà poussèrent mais toi
encore un peu plus vivre de lâcher prise
libre
parmi les miens
ivre d'amour
suspense